circling the Jade Sea is the dream of
every merchant and the other side is the
golden Empire Beauty which was ancient
when the Valyrians were still [ __ ]
goats even its ruins draw-off every city
in Westeros and his princess are said to
live in houses of solid gold and feast
on Mead powdered with pearls and Jade
foolish talk if it were true I would
have listed them long ago but a bold
merchant will risk two years for one
warrant to fatten his halls with spices
gems and silks so that he never wants
for anything again to be fair many never
do because my ship silence finds them on
their return their merchant dreams look
so pitiful poured out on my begs not
enough for any lifetime but their own
traders from the sama Islands make
tougher prey not even the Cylons can run
down their Swan ships on the open sea
when we take them by surprise
Iran spritzen crack against their hulls
cop from rare hardwoods of the summer
Islands and fit it together without a
single nail worse every Swan ship
carries a company of archers armed with
golden heart bows which can hurl the
chef's hard enough to pierce steel plate
after all that trouble we often find
their holes filled only with maps fruit
and wooden trinkets
hardly worth our time and blood except
for their women to worship their God old
women of the summer islands learn to
[ __ ] it's enough to make a man the mount
ever knees whalers are the most
worthless of prices the men of Eva Shah
thick and hairy
so are their women not even tales of
their six breasts contempt meant to take
them but the other knees know how to
build ships they're great bellied
whalers can weather any storm and
withstand the assaults of the largest
beasts in battle the Ebony's are
incredibly strong and even their blood
reeks of blubber and oil and their holds
a rally worth scrubbing our decks free
of the stench when our holes were full
or needed repair we set a course for the
greatest safe hub of the summer see the
basilisk Isles the port plunder sty
horse cash no map can find these towns
nor can the loss of men the slavers keep
their captives and caves in the Isle of
Tears pirates trade their goods and
barter Beach and hire fresh crews from
the murderers filling every
in great piles of old the yellow skulls
lined the shores of one desert done
offerings from captains who have fresh
heads into their mosques once every
generation of free city sent leads to
destroy the towns and hang every man
they find they do and the towns are
abandoned to rot and sink back into the
slime but come the next year another
port plunder sprouts up somewhere else
in the isle like a toadstool from a new
path [ __ ] for many years I brought
silence to the summer sea but when I
close my eyes I hear the waves breaking
below the bridges of Pyke
I hear the Kings smooth chanting my
brother's name
merchants paid the gold price buying
their desires with coin Rivas paid the
iron price taking what we want from the
corpses of the men who had it but for
when I dream no gold can buy no iron can
take I must pay with fire and blood
you